boris johnson you can love him
you can hate him but who is he
in some ways he's a very very familiar
figure he's a very colorful character
he has a very distinctive persona
and he's a global superstar my friends
we export
french knickers to france everybody
thinks they know him around the world
but the more you look at him is really
difficult to understand
because there are at least two very
distinctive boris johnsons
so let's find out more about who these
two boris johnsons are
one is of the globalist open-minded
person a liberal who's in favor of open
immigration
i've been one of the few british
politicians to speak up in favor of
of the benefits of immigration he has
turkish ancestry he has some jewish
ancestry he's a very cosmopolitan figure
my father's father's father was a muslim
and he knew large chunks of the quran
off by heart on the other hand he claims
to be the leader of
the nationalist populist sort of wing of
the conservative party
what do they know the impact of
immigration on school places
and hospital waiting lists and gp
surgeries they know nothing about it
they know absolutely nothing about it
he's more recently talked about muslim
women wearing burkas looking like
letterboxes and things like that so two
very very distinctive personas there
but he's hardly the anti-establishment
figure he claims to be
boris johnson is very much part of the
british upper classes
and he's got quite a name to show for it
alexander
boris defeld johnson he
went to eaton the english boys boarding
school
educated princess william and harry and
also 19 previous prime ministers
he went to oxford then he immediately
went in journalism
so he's really been a creature of
the english upper classes and of the
metropolitan
journalistic elite but with boris
things are never quite what they seem
well boris johnson has an extraordinary
history of lying in public his first job
was on the times
and he was sacked for making up a
quotation
then he went on in the telegraph to make
a number of claims
about the european union including the
fact that they wanted to straighten
bananas and things like that which were
either exaggerations or lies during the
referendum campaign he appeared all
around the country with buses
on the side of which were claims about
britain getting 350 million
back from the eu there is no evidence
that he'll be good at being precise with
his words
and there's a lot of evidence that he is
willing to say things that are flat out
false
okay so he's consistently inconsistent
doesn't rate facts too highly
and yet he's still flying high how boris
johnson has
enormous strengths he is a very very
good campaigner
he was re-elected as mayor of london
despite being a tory
and above all he makes people feel good
about themselves
i have nothing to say about this about
except of useful teeth there's a great
great and important qualities in the
politicians they're not enough but
they're certainly
important so who is the real boris
johnson
clown statesman or something else
altogether
i think boris johnson is a dangerous
politician
the rather narcissistic individual who
wants to be not just liked
but loved and that means that he's
willing to pander
bend the truth and when the going gets
really tough there's no evidence that he
can really
push through and solve problems i don't
think he really believes anything
and i think not believing anything in
good times
is probably all right but when you're in
very difficult times as britain most
certainly is at the moment
when you're the prime minister you need
to have a start and be guided by and i
don't
think he has a star to be guided by